c'est dans l'état c'est bien bas du dos
annales mother mme simonet shon
technology je suis fier je suis fier
quand je parle comme ça qu'on adule
c'est incroyable nous y sommes si vous
achetez une technologie c'est un jeu
hyper cool qui joue sur les perspectives
j'ai pas ce que j'avais des petites
vidéos il avait mis beaucoup de vannes
qui joue juste devant sur la perspective
et qui du coup ne fondera en marais
comme celui ci par exemple c'est un
petit jeu est graphiquement ça va être
dégueulasse mais par contre ça a l'air
d'être tournée cerveau et aujourd'hui on
veut se faire autour et le cerveau moi
j'adore la cmp les canaux ce gaz délicat
permet à médan d'être en pleine forme
au début mon gars ça déconne est bel et
bien venu au musée de la simulation
technologique c'est incroyable allez on
y va clic gauche pour attraper un truc à
a
c'est génial j'adore l'effet que ça fait
c'est immense à regarder si je vais en
bas c'est un truc immense et pourtant je
peux le porter dans ma main et on dirait
qu'il est tout petit regardez c'est trop
flou gars c'est génial pour une fois que
j'ai ça je fais quoi je le rejoins à
plus je le mets loin puis va être grand
c'est génial pour le brent butt monga
j'adore c'est génial donc plus je vais
baisser à guémar appui va être proche de
moi plus être petit plus éloignés pluie
va être grand et donc si je prends la
tour eiffel il faut que j'aille vers le
bas pour qu'elle devienne petit et que
j'aille vers le haut pour qu'elle
devienne grande c'est incroyable c'est
hyper bizarre tout jeu est basé sur ça
on va voir faire des petites énigmes
pour pouvoir accéder au niveau d'après
et c'est partie de la sphère des
escaliers pour aller là où je suppose
c'est sa race et un mini four qui va
devenir un vrai four
[ __ ] avec c'est génial c'est
génialissime je veux dire mille fois le
mot c'est génial passeur démarche avec
des fours l'art mais bon là on est bon
est là c'est parti ça me permet
d'accéder à la porte
voilà je pense à horizon assez facile
encore mais je pense à notre insu
compliqué la joconde sans les millions
de touristes habituellement posé devant
je peux la faire devenir immense ben
voilà c'est une grande joie au monde
passé par il faut que j'accède à la
hausse et ben écoute mais clos a volé
tableau va se faire avancer on va
avancer dans la vie c'est dur là comment
je sens et les faire tenir en équilibre
ah mais je pense qu'on est pareils
flancourt commence alors à temps comment
les poser pour pouvoir accéder à l'étagé
du dessus telle est la question
la joconde et est en place ou apprendre
vague on va le faire c'est couper avec
la joconde et normand poirier les mecs
sains
ah [ __ ] à la perspective est en train
de me brahim phoque mon cerveau fume
littéralement regarder la fumée sort de
mes oreilles c'est dur c'est très dur
j'arrive pas à mon coeur mon cerveau
n'arrive pas à comprendre ce qui se
passe un truc de malade quand même tu
sûr qu'il faut juste faire un pont avec
c'est sûr et là à temps oh ouais ce que
j'ai fait je n'ai même pas compris ce
qui s'est passé mais par contre ce que
je comprends c'est qu'on arrive je sais
pas comment ils ont géré le truc mais cc
ils ont mieux géré que nous en tout cas
ça c'est sûr activity times est freidman
pour les enfants comme cette vidéo c'est
pour les enfants
d'après bfm
ok c'est parti à bâle a compilé les
choses finalement comme tout à l'heure
rien de bien compliqué quand on va
mettre sur l'attrait atteint depuis le
jugement après un petit pont de manière
aisée voilà ce qui m'a s'exerce que je
fais je les empilent pas du tout va
faire cube rectangle cube rectangle à la
tu vois par exemple j'ai passé joué sur
la perspective pour le rendre grand
joueur je me retrouve un petit peu
coincé si tu vois ce que je veux dire on
n'est pas loin [ __ ] veto on peut voir
ce qui se passe que eux
yaka bon allez c'est le cul qui va nous
permettre de rejoindre la voie lactée
c'est faut aller [ __ ] mais non mais
non mais non mais c'est mais qu'est ce
que c'est que j'ai foutu là au nom non
mais quelle erreur n'a pas non mais les
gars mais soyez cool parfois s'il faut
prendre un cube et un deuxième est avec
deux pics manger pour y arriver
voilà ensuite sa voix là et maintenant
je peux y aller oh non mais la mecque
mais c'est scandaleux quoi c'est
vraiment mon gros orteil du bloc mais
non [ __ ] armées cema ram et voilà le
tour est joué
c'est qu'on n'a pas l'habitude de
pouvoir prendre un truc qui est loin
qu'ils le truc est immense et pour moi
mais je peux quand même le 1er et le 2
et le faire devenir petit pour enfin
bref oui cette phrase montre bien à quel
point mon cerveau ne peut plus attendu
que logiquement je dois refaire tomber
tout ça en bas on va tout mettre le long
des trucs et comme ça on ne pourra s'en
servir comme on le faisait pas que ça
tombe dans le dans la pataugeoire
ok je commence à prendre goût à cette
musique elle me donne vite swinguait
soir à suarez j'ai fait des calculs je
vais calcul scientifique gg me piller
tout dans mes calculs et vous allez voir
vous allez voir il n'y a pas de risque
en fait on va utiliser l'huile en
premier on est bon voilà voilà donc là
on peut monter et ensuite on va servir
des deux autres comme on a fait tout à
l'heure pour pouvoir atteindre la voie
lactée
tu veux pas tu veux pas être plus gros
noms mais c'est un sketch mais le truc
est devenu minuscule il faut que j'en
fasse grossir un peu à mes mecs j'ai
perdu le truc dont deux ans kate qu
arriver là attendons mais que ça pas du
tout gênant mais comment faire on va
faire une sorte d'escale et latéral je
suis architecte hockey merde merde je
viens de le perdre parmi leur faut que
quatre souvenez-vous de mon calcul eyed
peas mais je peux pas juste faire un
pont tout coup en fait en faisant ça je
me fatigue
je suis fatigué de moi voilà ça j'ai
fait bouger à sortir puis c'est que
cette merde
et ben voilà [ __ ] mais c'est j'adore
ce jeu il est génial faut monter là haut
oh merde comment on fait ça il ya un
ventilateur est ce qu'il faut pas faut
que je fasse devenir géant et ça à faire
tomber le pilier c'est un truc comme ça
c'est sûr pour faire tomber les clés de
la sortie
oui regardez ça bouge c'est génial avec
ses traumas l'un d'eux pour faire
grossir un objet qui a une fonction et
du coup sa fonction est décuplée [ __ ]
j'adore alors si un objet est entouré de
bleu faites un clic droit pour le faire
bouger de sens c'est une fusée donc sa
logique - il faut mettre ça là à la
verticale comme ça non c'est la merde
j'ai pas compris le but exact de cette
fusée est ce que je veux dire
peut-être que je la fasse à peut-être
attend à je peux attraper la lune
d'accord juste c'est malin mongai à la
sortie qui sur la lune
elle est là mais non mais non
c'est génial génial d'a1 je dis oui elle
va le suivant tellement va durer ce jeu
il m'envoie du [ __ ] de rêve alors eu
un truc avec des tabloïds pour savoir
faire et une fenêtre et là on peut
bouger la fenêtre ont fait grossir la
fenêtre est comme ça veut passé entre
les barreaux et le problème est réglé
j'adore il faut mais qu'il faut que vous
fassiez ce jeu mais sur une rallonge en
quoi ce sera encore plus ouf ou la
secousse bordel au il ya un délire de
portail
j'en ai fait grossir une à mort et du
coup ça grossit l'objet qui a derrière
et en quoi ça m'aide à trouver la sortie
les amis ce qui se passe là j'ai fait
des portails immense joie pour rien
changé de leur tout petit je veux plus
rien et oui la sortie dans l'histoire
avec haché compris en grandvaux la
strate c'est d'empiler les deux cuvées
d'atteindre la hauteur du mur et ensuite
foot l'un des portails en haut pour
pouvoir les sur le rebord du mur
à moins que ça soit je me trompe mais
totalement mon gars on sait pas voilà
c'est un truc du genre à temps je vais
arriver hop hop à butare je sens que je
ce mal qu'on n'est pas loin
pourquoi la bahia 1re un mur immense
c'est quoi ce délire pourquoi tout a
grossi et moi je suis devenu tout petit
mais là je comprends pas pourquoi quand
je passerai dans ce miroir géant en
frôlant le mur et en passant là pourquoi
ça vraiment quelqu'un de tout petits ah
parce que d'accord
holman feuilles de bâtard ok d'accord en
fait le jeu par rapport au portage doit
toujours faire la même taille par
rapport aux portails là quand je passe
est porté à 10 cm entre moi et le haut
de la porte
mais voilà dans le jeu c'est pareil tu
fais que quand je sors d'une porte
immense jeu devient immense et quand je
sors d'une porte petit jeu devient
microscopique attend dans ce faux ce que
j'ai dit ah bon dieu mais bon voilà là
je suis revenu dans le monde normal la
porte là bas et les cubes son petit ok
mais quand je vais dans le monde virtuel
que représente ce portail la up
je me retrouve à l'endroit qu'on vient
de voir où il y avait les deux cuvées la
porte
sauf que je suis microscopiques ça veut
donc dire qu'en fait quand je passe ici
je deviens j'ai en tête le but est de
devenir géante passé l'autre côté du mur
gpat en jeu contre attaque des titans
mon gars c'est incroyable il ya si je
retourne pas et ben voilà
et ben voilà on est passés olala c'est
génial les mecs ont râlé super loin donc
en fait depuis début on était juste
microscopiques et on a réussi à devenir
grand point de voir passer au delà du
mur donc c'est bel et bien la taille des
titans monga et donc on était en fait
sur un jeu d'échecs avec le mondiaux de
talent voilà tout n'est que tromperie
rt pour le complot alors les amis
sciemment de ce petit jeu
excellent n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo ça
vous a plu [ __ ] c'était hyper
intéressant comme je l aimais qui l'ont
poussé le truc et cette build là et
qu'on vient de jouer date de droit de
même plus d'un an j'espère monga que les
mecs qui bossent dessus encore à l'heure
actuelle alors heures perdues et qui
vont nous pondre un truc vraiment encore
plus magnifique parce que [ __ ] du coup
je trouve qu'un truc un truc à creuser
écoutez il est gratuit n'hésitez pas à
jouer vite fait pour bien vous rendre
compte de ce que ça fait en fait c'est
vraiment très moche pas si on se rend
bien compte en vidéo sur scène elle
projetait une vidéo portez vous bien sûr
tout le monde
au revoir
[Musique]